fuera de la oscuridad total pero no
fuera del túnel un día después de
haberse paralizado las dos principales
centrales eléctricas de líbano volvieron
a funcionar luego de que el ejército
suministrar a un total de 6000 kilos
litros de gasóleo el ministerio de
energía también ha recibido la
aprobación del banco central para pedir
un préstamo de 100 millones de dólares
para importar combustible para la
generación de electricidad pero las
empresas están al borde del colapso en
medio de la subida de los precios y el
empeoramiento de la crisis financiera
[Música]
antes había electricidad durante dos
horas una de día y dos de noche ahora no
hay nada estamos sobreviviendo estamos
gastando de nuestros ahorros y de
nuestras propias reservas pero después
de un tiempo cuando nuestros ahorros se
acaben no podremos seguir
el apagón total del sábado fue el
segundo que afectó al líbano este mes
con la moneda nacional en caída libre
los envíos de combustible del extranjero
se han agotado los que pueden
permitírselo han recurrido a generadores
privados pero el combustible para
alimentarlos también se ha vuelto
difícil de conseguir los precios de la
electricidad de las empresas privadas se
dispararon la energía generada por
empresa cuesta nada menos que 15
millones de libras libanesas cómo
podemos sobrevivir el sector de la
energía ha sido una enorme fuga para las
arcas del estado durante décadas con la
compañía nacional de servicios públicos
teniendo pérdidas anuales de hasta 1500
millones de dólares la reforma del
sector ha sido una exigencia clave de
prestamistas globales como el banco
mundial y el fondo monetario
internacional